One of my favorite apps is the Philosophical calculator. Like
a normal calculator, the first step is to give it
some input. Here, we're going to say, Right? AI, Knox
We could also supply files. But in this case, we're
going to go with a simple prompt. Now, the first
step in using the philosophical calculator, of course, is to
make sure we have some models selected. We're going with
haiku and Gemini flash image. And
then we start at the pipeline. Since our input is
fairly small, we're going to skip the summarize notes part
and go straight to draft article. We can run that
in the UI. And wait for it to complete. We
could view this session. To monitor it in real time
but this processing session is a one stop operation. Its
details aren't particularly interesting. For session detail
we will view that in depth when we execute lenses
which is next. But for now, We
have the completed draft article. That is shown in a
formatted preview. And now that we have the draft article
we can proceed to lenses. Here's where it gets really
interesting. The philosophical, the philosophical calculator provides a variety
of operations that you can perform on your draft article
It performs a variety of different analysis like brainstorming or
multi-perspective analysis or even writing a comic book about the
article. For demonstration purposes, let's
go with perspective analysis. I'm going to click run, and
in a second, a session link will pop up. This
session link allows us to monitor the, Multi
perspective analysis task in real time as it proceeds through
a multistep reasoning, change
The user interface you're seeing here is the standard user
interface for real-time. Um, Agents
For real-time agents and analysis. This will take a moment
because it will be going through a number of different
perspectives, and then finally it will synthesize the results, basically
summarize all of the perspectives. We can also in
the main UI go over to usage and we can
monitor the usage as it Uses tokens
So far, we have spent about 4 cents on this
process. Oh, the brains, the, uh, multi-perspective dialogue is ongoing
so it just use another penny. And
when it completes, the UI will, Update. We're only going
to run this one lens to demonstrate this module, but
you could run each of these, um, if you wanted
to in parallel. Depending on what you felt was appropriate
When these are completed, we can then go back to
the pipeline. And we can update the article, which will
take the output of all of the lens runs and
try to fold them back into the article to, Pick
up insights and new ideas. Other things like that. Perhaps
correcting issues. Looking
at lenses, this is, kind of almost complete. I saw
a synthesis here. Synthesis is, The last step in the
multi synthesis is the last step in the multi perspective
analysis. And
when it completes. There
we go. And we can see the detailed output
for a given, Lens run in the UI. Here we
see the multi perspective analysis transcript, which will detail, Each
perspective in turn. For example, this is
the competitive player perspective. It goes through each perspective, so
it's quite a long analysis, and at the end, you
will find, The synthesis and recommendations
section. Here we go. So, the lenses
generally involve a very long. Set of analysis
and then they conclude with a summary. Those summaries and
analysis can again be folded back into the original article
using the pipeline. However, for brevity's sake, uh, we will
skip that and demonstrate one last feature, the illustrate article
feature, which is, I think, one of the most entertaining
This takes your content in your article and designs
a number of illustrations. It can then weave into the
article for, um, there's a display issue. The session
link is shown. In the draft article section. Hopefully
they'll be fixed and released soon. And again, we can
monitor this in real time. It comes up with the
image ideas, and then it generates each image. Here
we go. And then after it generates each image
After it generates all of the images, it will. Create
it will integrate the images into the original documents by
editing the documents and adding in image links. OK
And now we see our article. Full of illustrations. For
62 cents, we have a fully illustrated guide to Connect
Four. This of course is merely
a demo. I hope you enjoy this tool and exploring
your own ideas.